Clear skin, blue eyes,
golden hair, and a well-proportioned face.
7 scenes of the goddess of love and beauty that are said to be elves, and
the scale tribe that competes beautifully in Hojo
, so it's proof of that.
It's no good, the ear-length north ridge is no different The two people on the right,
acknowledge and ask for forgiveness Rub your head on the ground
and give me my beauty
You can forgive me for just a box of
uniforms, anyway
You don't have to do that to the other person, even if it's exposed
to the public.
I'm not interested in women in the first place, but now that I've gotten used to seeing Chiba's nature, I
can't be fascinated
by you.
If you see me, I'll get on my knees and
listen to what you say All
the men in this village will bring the next thing,
right
?  And I think I'm beautiful
[music]
I sympathize with making you tan
Haa
I think you
're prettier No, I really can't compare.
Reconsider Yourself Woman
Why don't you start by changing the god you believe in?